OLIVIER de Weck: About
five years ago, we
started thinking about our
classes in the area of aircraft
systems and spacecraft
systems in the department.
And we started
realizing that there
was a particular class
that we didn't have,
and something that seemed
very important to us,
and also very important
to people in industry.
And that is a
general introduction
to systems engineering.
Systems engineering is
essentially the art and science
of coordinating and
putting together
the different
disciplines in order
to create safe, efficient
flying systems--
not just flying systems,
but systems in general.
And so we decided to create
a six-unit class, which
is a half class,
that would focus
on the methodology
and the processes
in systems engineering,
which is going all
the way from stakeholder
needs and expectations,
all the way to a
functioning system that
can be deployed in the field.
This class, 16842, is really
a door-opener to the world
of systems engineering.
And what we use in the
class to orient everybody
is the classic V-model
of systems engineering.
Now what is the V-model?
The V-model takes you
step-by-step through the life
cycle of a system, starting
with the left side of the V,
which is, why should the system
exist in the first place?
Who are the stakeholders?
What are their expectations?
How do you formulate a concept
of operations for a system?
And then go step-by-step
through the V,
through the requirements
definition, concept generation
and selection, driving the
system design, all the way
to the details, to every little
part, and piece, and component,
and then moving
up the right side
of the V, where you
integrate all these pieces
into subsystems and modules.
You do verification,
validation, testing.
You commission the system
and bring it into operations.
And even then, the
job isn't done.
You have to accompany the
system throughout its life cycle
through maintenance,
upgrades, repair,
making sure the system
is really operating
as efficiently as it can.
So what the class does is
take students systematically
through every portion of the
V, so that at the end of it,
they have a good overview over,
what is systems engineering?
And what are the key steps in
the life cycle of a system?